One of Neil's favorite experiments and mine is dropping red,
hot charcoal into liquid oxygen in a cauldron, a bowl.
You've seen it before, but now we're going to show it to you.
Like you've never seen it.
We're going to show you how we do the experiment from the very beginning.
And we're going to show it to with a thermal imaging camera.
So you can see which bits get hot,
which bits get cold and even see some of the temperatures.
The first thing is that you have to fetch some liquid nitrogen from the tank.
It's usually a bit of a chore, but when you look at the temperatures,
it's really quite interesting.
[Inaudible].
Once Neil did that, he had to carry the doers back to his lab,
where we can to make the liquid oxygen. Now,
liquid oxygen has a higher boiling point than liquid nitrogen.
And so you can condense liquid oxygen using
liquid nitrogen because it's colder.
So you begin with a cylinder,
that's a high pressure bottle of oxygen.
Now the pressure of the gas is far too high to use for the experiment.
So you have to reduce the pressure with a so-called regulator,
which sits on the top of the cylinder. Once you've got it flowing,
you flow it through coil of copper, copper conducts heat very well.
So if you put the coil of copper in the liquid nitrogen and flow the
oxygen through, it will liquefy,
But because there's a flow,
it goes right through and doesn't solidify in the coil.
[Inaudible].
So the gas comes out to the cylinder. It's a low pressure,
but flowing quite fast. It flows down to,
into the copper coil, which is cold in the coil it liquefies.
And when it liquefies the flowing gas blows through probably
droplets or slugs of liquid out of the other side,
and then it's fast enough so that it doesn't all boil away when it goes through
the last piece of tube. And then it goes into Thermo's flask.
We didn't have much oxygen. And because once it's in the bowl,
it will boil away quite quickly.
It was important to get the hot charcoal ready first because the
charcoal will gently burn in air. So once it's hot,
it will stay hot for quite a long time. So Neil heated,
the Chaco really light lighting, a barbecue.
[Inaudible].
Remember we only have one thermos of liquid oxygen.
And as soon as you pour something cold into the bowl,
which starts at room temperature, a lot of it will boil away.
So Neil didn't want to waste the oxygen.
So he cooled the bowl,
pre-cool it with liquid nitrogen,
because he has far more liquid nitrogen oxygen.
The bolts made of metal.
So it cools quite quickly because it doesn't have a very high heat capacity.
Once the boat is cold, when he paused in the liquid oxygen,
it will still boil a little bit, but it won't boil very violently.
So we won't waste.
So it goes the liquid oxygen into the pre-cool metrics.
[Inaudible].
Neil was ready. He had to contain it with several pieces of hot Choco. Now,
obviously when you drop them in, you have Choco, which is carbon,
which is going to burn really brightly and the presence of oxygen.
[Inaudible].
When it stopped in the ordinary video camera completely whites
out looks really good looks as if the whole world has ended,
but the thermal imaging camera looks very much more
selective wavelengths.
So you can actually see what's happening to the piece of childcare.
[Inaudible].
Not only can you see, but you can measure its temperature.
So you have two really good bits of scientific information.
[Inaudible].
There was a really interesting thing that happened.
One of the pieces that Neil dropped in, went the usual flash of light,
and nobody knew what was happening.
But Brady who was looking through the thermal imaging cameras said it's broken
into. And then when things had subsided, what has happened,
you could see, in fact, two pieces of charcoal, it's important to stress.
The liquid oxygen is very cold.
The charcoal is very hot.
It's somewhere between 900 and a degrees centigrade.
And so the way that these two can,
co-exist something that's very hot and something that's very cold is that
the shell code is probably surrounded by a bubble of gas.
Now you can't see that hot gas because it's probably not radiating in the same
way as the telco, but you do need to remember,
you can't have a liquid at minus nearly 200 degrees
centigrade in contact with the surface. That's a thousand degrees centigrade.
So the charcoal is surrounded by a cushion of air except it's
round.
So it's more like a bubble and that's important because of course the oxygen
gas gets much more efficiently to the surface to maintain the burning.
Eventually the reaction slows down and the oxygen
rushes in and cools down the remaining fragments of childco.
So probably when Neil washed it out,
he found some small pieces of charcoal bottom.
We thank Google's making and science initiative for helping us
make this video. If you want more information about the initiative,
look down in the video description.